.
>> NICE FIGHTING, KILLER.
>> SO WE ARE GOING TO SKIP AHEAD
FOR A MINUTE.
I WANT YOU TO CONSIDER WHAT WE
HAVE LEARNED SO FAR.
YOU ARE A NEW VAULT HUNTER AND
YOU JUST JOINED LILITH AND THE
CRIMSON RAIDERS.
OUR ENEMIES ON PANDORA ARE A
FANATICAL CULT CALLED THE
CHILDREN OF THE VAULT.
FROM HERE, YOU AND LILITH WILL
FIGHT SIDE BY SIDE TO CAPTURE
THE RECRUITING CENTER THAT
LILITH BELIEVES SHE CAN RECOVER
A KEY THAT WILL LEAD HER TO FIND
VAULTS ON OTHER WORLDS.
THE HUNT WILL EVENTUALLY LEAD US
HERE TO THE HOLY BROADCAST
CENTER WHERE A FEARSOME BANDIT
BOSS, MOUTHPIECE, BROADCAST
PROPAGANDA TO THE CHILDREN OF
THE VAULT ALL OVER PANDORA.
WHICH ARE HERE TO INVADE THE
HOLY RECRUIT MANY CENTER, FACE
MOUTHPIECE AND LIBERATE THE KEY
TO THE VAULT.
>> LIKE RANDY MENTIONED, WE
SKIPPED AHEAD IN THE STORY, IF
YOU NOTICE, WE SKIPPED AHEAD IN
LEVELS.I WANT TO TAKE THE TIME
TO SHOW YOU THE SKILLS IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
SO WHEN YOU FIRST GET YOUR
SKILLS IN BORDERLANDS 3, YOU
DON'T HAVE ONE ACTION SKILL
AVAILABLE TO YOU, YOU HAVE ALL
THREE ACTION SKILLS AVAILABLE TO
YOU AT THE MOMENT YOU OPEN IT
UP.
SO THEN, WHAT YOU DO, YOU QUIP
ONE OF YOUR ACTION SKILLS.
YOU WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
ACTION SKILLS?
SO THIS FIRST ONE, IT IS
PHASEGRASS, WILL BE REMINISCENT
OF MAYA, CONTROL THE BATTLEFIELD
IN LIFTING ENEMIES UP TO THE
AIR.
THE NEXT ONE HERE IS PHASECAST.
AND PHASELAM, IT IS AN AREA OF
EFFECT THAT COMES OUT AROUND
AMARA AND DESTROYS ENEMIES AND
KNOCKS THEM BACK.
AS YOU PROGRESS, ONCE YOU PICK
YOUR ACTION SKILL AND QUIP IT,
ALSO OPEN UP AUGMENTATIONS THAT
ALLOW YOU TO FURTHER CUSTOMIZE
THAT ACTION SKILL.
MAXIMIZE THE SKILL OF YOUR
CHARACTER.
WE WORKED HARD THAT EACH OF THE
FOUR CHARACTERS ARE COMPLETELY
UNIQUE.
EVEN WITHIN EACH CHARACTER,
HUNDREDS OF MEANINGFUL OPTIONS.
IF TWO PEOPLE WANT TO TEAM UP
AND PLAY THE SAME CHARACTER,
VERY LIKELY HAVE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT CAPABILITIES.
>> YOU READY TO GO?
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> LEVEL UP.
ALL RIGHT.
LEVELED UP.
>> ONE THING TO LOOK OUT FOR,
LOOK AT THE DAMAGE NUMBERS THAT
COME UP OFF THE ENEMIES.
WE'LL USE SOME OF THE
INFORMATION LATER.
LOOK AT NUMBER, 56, 26.
>> 26 IS THERE.
>> OH.
>> NOW THAT IS A HIGH PERIOD
SHOTGUNS.
HIGH PERIOD SHOTGUNS HAVE
SHIELDS THAT COME OUT.
>> SWITCH BACK TO THE SHOTGUN.
[ MUSIC ]
>> IT IS A NEW ELEMENT TYPE,
RADIATION.
>> HIT CRITICAL MASS.
>> AT THE RADIATED ENEMY DIE, HE
WILL EXPLODE AND RADIATE THE
ENEMIES AROUND HIM.
>> OKAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> THAT IS MAYHEM.
I THINK THAT HE CLEANED THIS
AREA UP.
LET'S SEE WHAT KIND OF LOOT WE
CAN FIND.
THAT IS AN OUTHOUSE BUT A GREEN
LIGHT.
SOME GOOD STUFF.
LET'S SEE HERE.
SO AMARA'S LEVEL 5, THESE
WEAPONS ARE LEVEL 5.
I WANT YOU TO NOTICE THAT,
NOTICE THE TWO HERE.
WE HAVE A RARE AND EPIC.
BOTH LEVEL 5.
AND THE REASON I WANT YOU TO
REMEMBER THAT, IS BECAUSE THAT
WAS KIND OF A CHALLENGING FIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO NEED SOME HELP
FOR THE NEXT SECTION.
WE WILL BRING THIS A CO-OP
BUDDY.
CO-OP PLAYABLE, SPLIT SCREEN,
NETWORK, HOWEVER YOU WOULD LIKE
TO PLAY.
AMARA PICKED UP THE PURPLE.
LET'S TURNAROUND AND FIND OUR
CO-OP BUDDY.
THIS IS ZANE FLYNT.
THE OPERATIVE.
WE WILL SWITCH TO ZANE'S VIEW.
CAN WE FLIP THAT?
I WANT YOU TO NOTICE SOMETHING
HERE.
ZANE IS LEVEL 25.
OBVIOUSLY ZANE HAS BEEN PLAYING
LONGER THAN AMARA THAT IS LEVEL
5.
IF WE LOOK AT ZANE'S LOOT, HE
HAS HIS OWN INSTANCE OF LOOT.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
THIS IS CALLED LOOT INSTANCING,
IT IS A NEW OPTIONAL FEATURE IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
IT ALLOWS EACH COOPERATIVE
PLAYER TO HAVE THEIR OWN
INSTANCE OF LOOT.
INSTANCE LOOT IS HELPFUL FOR
PLAYERS THAT WANT TO PLAY
COOPERATIVELY BUT DON'T WANT TO
COMPETE FOR THE LOOT THAT DROPS.
NOTHING WORSE THAN GETTING ON
LEAN WITH RANDOMS AND A LOOT
NINJA IN THE GROUP, RIGHT?
INSTANCE LOOT SOLVES THAT
PROBLEM FOR PLAYERS THAT WANT TO
USE IT.
THE OTHER FEATURE THAT
COMPLEMENTS THIS IS LEVEL
BALANCING.
NOTICE HOW ZANE'S LOOT IS NOT
ONLY INSTANCED, BUT IT IS
ACTUALLY BALANCED FOR HIS LEVEL.
THAT MEANS THE LOOT, THE
ENEMIES, EVERYTHING
AUTOMATICALLY BALANCES TO THE
LEVEL OF THE PLAYER SO THAT
EVERYONE HAS A GOOD TIME.
AND MY COI DON'T KNOW GROUP,
SOME OF US WOULD GET AHEAD OF
THE OTHER, RIGHT?
THEN BACK TOGETHER, OUT OF
WHACK.
WITH INSTANCE LOOT AND THIS MODE
OF GAMEPLAY, EVERYTHING BALANCES
OUT.
>> NOW, THAT IS OKAY.
AND YOU CAN CLAP IF YOU WOULD
LIKE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
NOW THERE ARE STILL SOME OF US
WHO ACTUALLY LIKE COMPETING FOR
LOOT OR BRINGING IN OVERPOWERED
CHARACTERS TO HELP LEVEL UP THE
LOWER LEVEL CHARACTERS.
FOR THOSE WHO ARE LIKE THAT, WE
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT THERE IS
STILL A MODE FOR YOU IN
BORDERLANDS 3.
IT IS CALLED CLASSIC MODE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
NOW THAT WE HAVE SEEN ZANE THE
OPERATIVE, LET'S HAVE A LOOK AT
WHAT HE CAN DO.
ZANE IS LEVEL 25.
WE EQUIPPED A LOT OF ACTION
SKILLS AND SKILL POINTS HERE.
YOU WANT TO WALK US THROUGH
THIS, PAUL IN.
>> LET'S DO THIS.
THE FIRST SKILL WE HAVE IS DING
DALE DIGICLONE.
IT WILL SHOOT GUNS AS WELL.
MY FAVORITE FEATURE, TELEPORT TO
DIGICLONE AND SWAP PLACES.
THIS IS DRONE THAT WILL THREE
OUT OR WEAKEN THE ENEMIES OR USE
GRENADES IF YOU HAVE GRENADE
MODE EQUIPPED.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE BARRIER
SKILL.
NOW ZANE WILL THROW OUT A
BARRIER IN FRONT OF IT AND BLOCK
INCOMING BULLETS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
ONE OF THE COOLEST FEATURE, IF
YOUR TEAM OR ZANE IS AROUND
THIS, CONFIRM BENEFITS LIKE
HEALING, EVEN IF YOU HIRE
THROUGH IT, ADD ELEMENTAL TYPES
TO THAT.
NOW PROBABLY MY FAVORITE FEATURE
OF ZANE IS THE FACT THAT ZANE
CAN USE TWO ACTION SKILLS AT ONE
TIME.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT ZANE, RIGHT?
HE HAS HIS BARRIER, WHICH IS
KIND OF LIKE THE SOLDIER CLASS'S
CAPABILITY.
HE HAS THE SENTINEL WHICH IS
LIKE MORDECAI BLOOD WING BUT
HYPED UP FROM THAT.
HE HAS THE DIGICLONE, LIKE OUR
SKILL FROM BORDERLANDS 2.
HE IS LIKE A SOLDIER, ASSASSIN
WRAPPED UP IN ONE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE AMARA, ZANE, WE KNOW
WHAT THEY CAN DO.
LET'S GET INTO THE HOLY
BROADCAST CENTER TO TO SEE IF WE
CAN FIND MOUTHPIECE.
>> OOPSY.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A TECHNICAL
ISSUE.
DON'T WORRY.
WE'LL POST THE WELCOME BID LATER
ALONG WITH SOME NEW, LET'S PLAY.
SIGNING OFF FOR NOW.
DON'T FORGET TO LIKE, FOLLOW AND
OBEY.
>> ANOTHER PERFECT LIVE STREAM
FROM OUR INFALLIBLE GOD QUEEN
TYREEN.
THE HOLY BROADCASTER OPENS ONCE
AGAIN TO HEAR YOUR SINS AND
RECEIVE YOUR SKINS!
>> OUCH!
>> TYREEN!
>> WHEW!
STILL GOT IT!
>> THESE ARE THE EMBARKING
TARGETS FOR THE SENTINEL.
ALSO CHECK OUT THE DAMAGE
NUMBERS, RIGHT?
HIS ENEMIES ARE LEVEL 27.
BUT HIS DAMAGE IS DOWN TO
AMARA'S GAME.
BECAUSE HE IS IN AMARA'S GAME
RIGHT NOW.
FOR AMARA, THOSE ENEMIES ARE
LEVEL 5.
ALL RIGHT.
WE CLEAN THIS AREA UP.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN FIND SOME
LOOT.
OKAY.
NOW ONCE AGAIN, BEING HONEST,
YOU KNOW, TO SHOW THE BREAD OF
GUN, SOME OF THE BREAD.
WE CHEATED AND ADDED SOME CHESTS
WITH BETTER WEAPONS.
>> THAT RED CHEST WON'T BE IN
THE GAME YOU PLAY.
WE ADDED THAT FOR THIS PURPOSE.
IT IS OKAY.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF RED CHESTS.
YOU'LL BE FIND.
WE'LL FEED YOU BABY BERDS.
WE WANTED TO SHOW YOU SOME TEDO,
INSTEAD OF RELOADING, YOU THROW
THEM AWAY.
WHEN YOU THROW AWAY THEM IN
BORDERLANDS 3, SOME CRAZY [
EXPLETIVE ] CAN HAPPEN.
GUNS WITH LEGS.
LET'S SEE SOME OTHER OPTIONS.
WHAT DOES THIS ONE DO?
WE PICKED SOME DISTRICT OF [IND]
WEAPONS, AND GO INTO THE FIGHT.
>> WE AREN'T GOING TO LEARN.
KEEPING THOSE SPEAKERS.
>> OH, IT IS ADORABLE.
>> YOU CAN SEE THAT ONE MERV'S
ROCKETS OUT.
>> THROW A MERV GUN OUT.
CHECK THIS OUT.
CALMING ROCKETS.
THAT WAS A LITTLE CLOSE TO THE
EARS.
>> OH, GOODBYE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AND YOU GUYS READY?
OH, YOU LEARNED!
WE CAN DODGE THAT.
>> THAT IS WICKED.
I SEE SOME AMMUNITION VENDING
MACHINES.
WALK UP TO THAT AMMO VENDING
MACHINE.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU THIS.
HE IS ALREADY FULL ON AMMO.
YOU JUST PRESS Y RIGHT THERE AND
RELOAD ALL OF THE AMMO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO IN AND BUY
THINGS ONE AT A TIME.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OF COURSE, YOU CAN BUY
INDIVIDUAL PIECES IF YOU WANT.
NOW, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU GUY,
WHEN YOU PLAY A VIDEO GAME AND
HAPPEN UPON A ROOM WHERE THERE
IS AMMO AND VENDING MACHINES TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE STOCKED
UP, YOU ARE A SAFE BET THAT YOU
ARE ABOUT TO RUN INTO A BOSS
FIGHT.
NOT ONLY BORDERLANDS A A MUCH,
MUCH LARGER GAME THAN BEFORE IT,
MORE BOSS FIGHTS THAN EVER
BEFORE.
WE THINK BOSS FIGHTS ARE
EXCITING OPPORTUNITY FOR PLAYERS
TO HAVE SKILL TESTED AND
REWARDED WITH KICK [ EXPLETIVE ]
LOOT.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND SEE IF WE CAN
FIND MOUTHPIECE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
[ MUSIC ]
>> YOU WILL DIE!
>> THIS SHIELDS LIKE AN
EQUALIZER.
ZANE USED HIS TELEPORT TO DODGE
THAT AREA OF EFFECT THAT
MOUTHPIECE JUST MADE.
OH [ EXPLETIVE ].
>> IS THAT ALL YOU GOT?
OH!
>> OH, GOD.
YOU NEED IT.
>> YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE LOOT,
MAN.
SOME LOOT OVER THERE.
>> GET THE LOOT.
>> DID YOU SEE THE GUN THAT
MOUTHPIECE WAS SHOOTING AT US
WITH SOUND WAVES FLYING OUT?
CHECK THIS OUT.
[APPLAUSE] ONE OF THE GREATEST
FEELINGS IN BORDERLANDS IS WHEN
AN ENEMY IS USING A GUN AGAINST
YOU, YOU KILL THAT GUY AND TAKE
THAT GUN AND USE IT AGAINST YOUR
NEXT ONE.
I LOVE THAT SO MUCH.
>> WELL, LET'S DO WHAT WE CAME
HERE FOR.
LET'S GET THE VAULT MAP.
>> AMARA WILL YOU PICK THAT UP?
>> HAVE YOU COME ALL THIS WAY
WITH THAT BUSTED [ EXPLETIVE ]
MAP?
OR SEE ME?
I DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE A SUPER
FAN.
AND YOU MISSED THE SHOW.
WHAT IS UP WITH THE HUGS?
IT IS A THING I DO.
CHECK OUT THE SCREENS.
SO I OFFERED THE SONS MATCHES A
PLACE IN MY FAMILY BUT THEY JUST
WANTED GUNS AND CATCH.
THEY BETRAYED THE FAMILY.
THEN, SAID SOMETHING GREAT.
>> GODS DON'T NEGOTIATE.
>> GODS DON'T NEGOTIATE?
I LOVE IT!
LOVE IT!
LIKE I SAID, THAT MAP IS SUPER
BUSTED.
GO AHEAD AND TAKE IT.
I'LL SWING BY LATER TO PICK IT
UP.
YOU ARE MY MOST LOYAL FOLLOWER
VAULT.
AND YOU JUST DON'T KNOW IT YET.
>> SO YOU HAVE JUST MET TRY AND
TYREEN KAL CALYPSO.
THE